alguna vez se han preguntado qué pasaría
si tratáramos a nuestro planeta como un
ser vivo podría parecer como absurdo tal
vez raro tratar a nuestro mundo como un
igual como cualquier persona que vemos
en la calle caminando no nos parece raro
si es así les voy a explicar por qué a
mí no me parece raro nuestro planeta en
la actualidad se cree el único habitable
se están haciendo investigaciones sí
pero
qué tal si no hay un reemplazo si este
es el único lugar donde podemos existir
con todo lo demás que hay conocen algo
que le recuerda esto piensa en un
momento
alguien tiene algo
bueno si si no lo sabían igual y la
película de disney es un claro
recordatorio de lo que tenemos que
empezar a hacer para prevenir una
tragedia y no una tragedia por ejemplo
familiar que a muchos de nosotros nos
puede haber pasado
una tragedia global
gracias
este así como decía
los problemas que nuestro mundo enfrente
en la actualidad son los más grandes de
la historia
estamos hablando de contaminación
sobrepoblación agotamiento de recursos
y la extinción de muchas especies
el calentamiento global analicemos los
problemas uno pensaría que por estos
grandes problemas que enfrentamos hoy en
día se generan por situaciones muy
complejas pero la realidad es que no
estos problemas se forman de una forma
mucho más simple de lo que cualquiera de
nosotros esperaría por ejemplo la
sobrepoblación porque a mediados de los
1900 la gente se empezó a reproducir
como cuyos
es la verdad por ejemplo mi abuelo llegó
a tener 13 hermanos además que el
imagínense lo complicado que fue sacar a
todos sus hermanos menores adelante y
así mismo y no sólo el pse de muchas
personas que probablemente en sus
abuelos y sus bisabuelos se re
producieron
horrible y eso llegó al siguiente
problema el agotamiento de recursos que
pasa mientras más gente hay más demanda
qué pasa cuando hay más demanda más se
requieren más recursos entonces nos
estamos acabando y como todo en la vida
hay dos opciones uno quedarse sentados a
esperar a que todo empeore y no hacer
nada o dos hacer entre todos un cambio
significativo apoyándonos entre todos
esté mi generación y probablemente las
que vienen después de la mía se enfoca
en dos cosas trabajo escuela y ellos
mismos para mí no hay un ejemplo más
claro que este es un círculo de egoísmo
que impide a uno tratar de pensar en
algo más que no está dentro de sus
intereses y tengo un ejemplo muy claro
yo mismo hace algunos años era la
persona más de egoísta que pudo haber
pisado este planeta
solo me interesaban tres cosas yo mismo
me beneficio y miguel nada más y un día
me puse a pensar yo podría cambiar al
mundo sin con esfuerzo con y no no sólo
nadie puede hacer esto solo todos
necesitamos apoyo pero bueno este no es
el punto este
a lo largo de la historia ha habido
mucha gente que ha colaborado para hacer
cambios significativos que han
beneficiado a la humanidad porque además
de los problemas que acabo de mencionar
están en los ámbitos político económico
y social si bien hay países que son
líderes en estas tres pero hay otros que
están completamente ahogados por ejemplo
siria pakistán y no sólo por decir
países africanos o asiáticos venezuela
como está venezuela todos sabemos que
está de la patada y va a empeorar
se va de guatemala a guatepeor
pero si todos colaboramos y salvamos a
nuestro planeta sería una historia
diferente
las personas sobre todo somos parásitos
en este planeta consumimos todo lo que
vemos o solo lo transformamos para
posteriormente consumirlo y no sólo las
personas cualquier ser vivo en este
planeta es un parásito somos tremendos
parásitos glotones
no solo de comida por ejemplo cuántos de
nosotros hacemos el consumo
irresponsable compramos 5 veces más de
lo que necesitamos en cualquier
supermercado eso es algo mucho más común
de lo que creemos
y te tiene que cambiar yo pienso que
ahora nos toca a nosotros los jóvenes
hacer el cambio vamos a liderar en un
futuro a este planeta y la verdad no
quiero que eso lo lideremos al fracaso
porque como va ahora es a donde pinta
así que yo les propongo bueno hay muchas
cosas que proponer para este tema está
de servicio comunitario la energía
alternativa las nuevas tecnologías y hay
muchos países que ya están poniendo en
práctica porque nosotros no fácil flojos
y creídos esos somos en este momento así
que si yo pensé muchas veces que esto
esta posición en la que soy para llevar
a cabo eso mi misión sería imposible
pero eso fue lo que me motivó a
presentarme aquí frente a ustedes saber
que esta situación sería muy difícil y
que sería aún más difícil llevarla a
cabo fue lo que nos motivó
a presentarme en frente a todos ustedes
y los invito para que igual se motiven
de la misma forma que yo para que juntos
realicemos el cambio y
luchemos para preservar nuestro futuro
así que estamos esperando muchas
[Aplausos]